vient tout juste d'arriver ici au sein
de l'hôpital Marie Lannelongue au
Plessis-Robinson il était à bord d'une
ambulance escortée par la police si moto
et deux voitures va suivre un traitement
de 48 heures l'établissement et
spécialisé dans la chirurgie du thorax
des vaisseaux et du cœur il dépend donc
de l'administration pénitentiaire de
Fresnes une détention provisoire qui se
poursuit donc ici au sein de l'hôpital
Marie Lannelongue car les médecins
estiment que pour le moment son état de
santé n'est pas compatible avec une
incarcération dans une maison d'arrêt
Gilles alors beaucoup de gens se sont
interrogés sur et on peut en débattre
sur l'importance du convoi mais il faut
bien noter que c'est pas un transfert
uniquement pour raison de santé d'un
individu lambda c'est un détenu
sensible un des plus surveillés de
France on l'a dit l'autre jour avec des
gens devant sa porte pour le surveiller
ce qui est transféré dans un autre
hôpital donc là c'est ultra sensible il
y avait une escort pourquoi il y a une
escort parce qu'on ne sait jamais il
peut y avoir une tentative de fuite il
peut y avoir des conneries
pourquoi il y a deux voitures Simota
agressé mais
peut-être lui d'être agressé
hypersensible
en VTC il partait tout seul
en tout cas il est sorti il est pas en
fait moi j'habite juste à côté de
l'hôpital il est passé ce vraiment dans
ma rue
c'était c'était toute sirène hurlante
quoi c'était quand même impressionnant
c'est pas de regarder
et les images elles parlent
d'elles-mêmes là je suis désolé on ne
peut pas dire qu'on lui accorde pas un
traitement de faveur il y a énormément
de motards il y a énormément d'ambulance
ils ont peur de quoi qui s'enfuit qu'il
y ait une émeute il se passe rien du
tout il a aussi été transféré dans le
meilleur centre c'est pas non plus
facile d'avoir des places dans les
meilleures hôpitaux donc on ne peut pas
dire qu'il bénéficient pas d'un
traitement de faveur parce qu'il est
connu je suis désolé mais peut-être
qu'ils craignaient aussi soit suivi par
euh
beaucoup de choses
justement tu fais plus remarquer comme
ça crée des accidents parce que les
motards les motards avec le journaliste
qui ont des courses poursuites pour
prenais de moto devant l'ambulance ça
suffisait à une moto devant une moto
derrière lui teinter et craint rien pas
de photo il allait à l'hôpital
tranquillement là c'est vraiment un
cirque traumatisé comme il est je pense
pas qu'il va sauver il a pas envie de se
sauver je crois quoi il va faire quoi je
crois que c'est
tu crois pas quand ils sont passés
on y va mollo
mais Gilles Verdez qui nous dit c'est le
détenu le plus
dangereux de France
[Rires]
incroyable j'ai pas dit dangereux j'ai
dit surveiller
en ce moment deux policiers devant sa
porte qu'elle détenue suscite l'intérêt
de tous les médias français je crois que
vous vous rendez pas compte honnêtement
de de l'impact de cette affaire en
discuter et alors pour le moment en tout
cas son état de santé n'est pas
compatible avec une détention classique
et ça va durer parce que là il y a une
opération etc et non mais Cyril il est
hyper surveillé je suis désolé tu vois